- [Narrator] This is a story about butter
that you never knew you always wanted.
Hopefully.
(upbeat music)
We begin before the appetizers arrive
when the bread comes with the butter.
But this butter, this
is the star of the meal.
It can be found in a town
in France called Saint-Malo
from a family called Bordier.
Jean-Yves is the main
butter guy these days.
Look at all these
different kinds of butter.
The third generation in a
line of butter making royalty.
- [Narrator] And the
butter here is different.
The butter we are going to
talk about (finally, right?)
is full of seaweed and used
by some of the best chefs
in the world.
- [Narrator] But then something happened.
Something big.
- [Narrator] Joël Robuchon
was a French chef.
In 1989, he was named chef of the century.
He has 32 Michelin
stars, more than a dozen
restaurants around the
world, 19 cookbooks.
He ran a syndicated
television show in France,
and perhaps at the end of the
day he will be best remembered
for his mashed potatoes.
- [Narrator] I feel like
the one question everyone
who is still watching
this video wants to know
is what it tastes like.
What does seaweed butter taste like?